olha só a nati eu sou adísia essa joana
e eu sou doida
nós somos idéia em movimento e hoje a
gente vai apresentar para vocês
a nossa perspectiva de uma aula
diferente vocês já pararam para pensar
que a sala de aula nunca mudaram de
formato sempre foram dentro de um espaço
físico determinado por quatro paredes
quase para alunos sentados e professores
empenho frente o quadro às vezes um
tatuado aulas muito positivas
se tentarmos desenhar uma sala de aula
vamos automaticamente pensar em uma sala
de aula típica
se vocês pensarem imaginem por cinco
segundos uma sala de aula após que a
maioria de vocês mas não a mesma coisa
bom a sala de aula nunca mudaram
elas realmente nunca mudaram ela sempre
foram iguais
ela sempre tiveram o mesmo formato
professor de pé e os alunos sentados
atrás
desde o século 19 a sala de aula
continua assim até hoje em dia
por mais que agora elas sejam mais
modernos
elas continuam com esse sistema o
professor de pele ou sentado nos
quadrinhos desenhos e filmes por mais
que o diretor possa mudar a a sala de
aula ele não muda porque a visão que
todos nós temos dela é como ela
realmente hoje na educação infantil a
sala de aula são um pouco mais coloridas
e mais alegres
porém o professor continuando a frente
no ensino fundamental até a faculdade a
sala já começam a ficar bem - diz
coloridas e mais monótonos
o professor tem um pouco mais autoridade
sobre os alunos às salas de aulas
poderiam ser regulares redondas em quase
100 quilates e com alunos ensinando e
mais trocas de experiência
podemos pensar que as salas de aula são
qualquer lugar há a sala de aula é o
mundo
a gente preparou pra vocês uma dinâmica
para mostrar que a gente pode render
muitos lugares diferentes
hoje em dia a maioria das pessoas pensa
que é só na sala de aula que se aprende
mas não é
também é na sala de aula que se aprende
a gente quer pra mostrar pra vocês com
essa dinâmica dinâmica que a gente pode
aprender com pessoas diferentes e com
experiências diferentes
a gente pode aprender e dar um passeio
no parque com a família com o cachorro a
gente também pode aprendendo ao clube
tomar banho de piscina com os amigos a
gente pode aprender fazer uma visita na
casa da avó
podemos aprender fazendo uma viagem com
a família e com os amigos indo ver um
filme e até mesmo passeando na rua
apesar de sabermos que é possível
aprender e ensinar em qualquer lugar
a escola ainda uma protagonista como vi
como vimos que as salas de aula
parecem ser sempre as mesmas resolveu
juntar às crianças o que elas acham
deste espaço
nós perguntamos a elas se você pode o
professor o que essa aula teria como
você faria para ela ficar mais legal e
como fazer para que os alunos participem
mais da aula e com as respostas a gente
um monto um vídeo que será passado para
vocês agora
- cash os temas apresentados
três pacientes
jorge é muito gostosa
a itália
thiaguinho e se divertir nef alunos não
terminava vamos que irão viver numa ilha
quem não queria dar essas coisas por
exemplo num mais jogos mas a leitura
mais alta hoje a xii e no final é uma
viagem pra mim poder brincar com a saúde
no final da operação poderia ter o nível
é pra gente ou então a telinha a
genitais no computador e mapas fazer
mas é o chefe e ele é que há uma
dificuldade a mais
ela chegou
tiago não sei
tchau como a gente poderia ter mais
livros chega completa ana como se nas
classes tivesse uma tela interativa seu
professor estivesse explicando sobre a
chegada dos italianos ac e mostrasse o
mapa com mais ou menos com o caminho que
eles fizeram as músicas mais jogos
a lousa ajuda de cada um de homens e bia
trabalhos legais e matérias novas
é do jogo
a igreja
toda e ele estava longe de ser o mesmo
entende bem as coisas para eles é os
colegas no rio ela pergunta é aquele que
ele já tem bastante já prevê erguer bem
alto também não dando muito trabalho
cinza pode fazer num dia só espero que
os trabalhos se precisassem sair em
grupos pra ter a resposta é a opinião de
cada um não seria curiosidade pra eles
ficarem mais atentos na água
podemos ver que não é preciso muita
coisa apenas uma mudança de pensamento
para termos uma aula que motiva os
alunos
pensando nisso resolvemos fazer algo
para motivar as crianças em relação ao
aprendizado
criamos um projeto que chamamos de idéia
e movimento
estamos lançando este projecto hoje
vamos apresentar ele pra vocês
esperamos que gostem e apanham as idéias
a a gente vai passar agora um vídeo
sobre a proposta do nosso projeto
vou a gente está procurando a gente está
procurando uma escola e pessoas
interessadas para que possam nos ajudar
a realizar esse projeto ea gente queria
agradecer por mês está nos assistindo
aqui hoje obrigada obrigada